DIRK STAHLECKER: So I thought
that this class would allow me
an opportunity to, first off,
create some sort of application
or product that would be
interesting and enjoyable
to make and, more importantly,
have an actual impact.
It would be working with
someone and doing something
that would directly benefit
them and allow them to improve
their daily lives in some way.
That gives it a lot more
meaning and a lot more power,
and makes it a lot more
enjoyable of an experience
to create.
So, I really wasn't
entirely sure
what it all would
entail initially.
I knew we'd be working
with the clients,
and I knew we'd be
creating a product,
but I didn't realize
all of the focus that
would be put on
looking at the client,
the contextual
analysis, figuring out
what it is that the clients can
do, wants to do, is able to do.
And there was a lot
of focus on features
other than directly creating the
piece of assistive technology.
And I didn't expect that
that would be the case.
But I realized it was
critical that that was there.
Because to really make
something successful,
you have to understand all of
the context surrounding it.
And to do something
that is really useful,
you have to know what it
is that the client needs.
That's applicable both in an
assistive technology and just
in working toward
it for any client.
ARTHI VEZHAVENDAN: So
I came into this class
hoping that I would be able to
work on a project that actually
had an impact, because most of
the courses I had taken at MIT,
they were theoretical.
And you just work
on problem sets,
and you hope to apply the things
that you learned after college.
And so the last semester
and this semester,
I've been trying to find
courses where I can actually
use those skills immediately.
And I feel like practicing
those skills is actually
what's going to help
me learn them better,
so learning through experience.
And that's exactly what
I got out of this class.
I was able to apply the web
design skills that I learned,
and also just the whole
design process that we
were told about, but actually
apply it into [INAUDIBLE].
DIRK STAHLECKER: I learned
that there is always
a lot more than meets the eye.
I realized that
there's a lot of-- I
was surprised working
with both our client
and hearing about the
other clients in the class,
how much they were able to do,
even given their disabilities.
They were very well able
to do quite a lot of things
that I wouldn't have
expected them to be able to.
You have to really focus
on what their abilities are
and what their needs are.
And I think having a client
there in the first place
gave us this level of
focus that is normally not
found in creating, in our
case, a software application.
We're looking at
a particular user
and focusing on what one
particular person wants.
And that made it a lot easier to
know what direction to take it,
rather than having some nebulous
group of our supposed users
out there that we didn't
actually know or interact with.
I put in a lot of
time at the beginning
to understanding the context and
the client and the situation.
And it's really tempting to
jump right in and start coding,
and we didn't do that.
And I'm glad we didn't
do that, because we
were able to
understand what it was
we were supposed to be doing
and what direction we needed
to take.
So I think that's the
biggest piece of advice
there, is to not start
coding right away,
but make sure you really
understand what you're doing.
ARTHI VEZHAVENDAN: So we went
through a bunch of iterations.
First, we started off
with-- Originally,
we just discussed
with our client
what he wanted,
what his needs were.
So we had four
people in our group,
and we each
separated and came up
with our own ideas of what
the client might want.
And so we came up
with paper prototypes.
And then we brought these four
versions into the next meeting
and discussed what--
Our client told us
what he liked about them and
what he didn't like about them.
And so from that we've
collaborated and put those
four together into a
final paper prototype.
And then just kept
iterating from there,
going back to our client, asking
what he liked about it, what
he didn't like about it.
And then once we had a
pretty finalized version
of what we were hoping to
get out of this project,
we went into actually
starting to code it
and separating the
tasks and everything.
The most challenging
aspect was probably
while going through all
these iterations and coding,
I kind of want to say it was
the actual implementation.
So coming up with the ideas
and everything it was great.
It was like a lot of
creativity and trying
to fix these problems.
But then actually going
into the coding portion
was when we came
into the bugs of how
do we actually implement what
we want out of our project.
We know that we want a
certain type of screen there.
We know how we want the
user to interact with it.
But how do we actually
do this technically?
And that was one of the
challenging parts of the class.
DIRK STAHLECKER: I think
the blogs were really
a time for reflection
and thinking
about what it was we were doing.
I used the blogs, at
least, as sort of a way
to catalyze my analysis
of the subjects
and the material presented
in class and the things
we've been working on.
So I took it and really
looked to analyze
some thought I had been having,
trying to figure out how to
[INAUDIBLE] one on, how to
make computers more accessible,
and ways in which that is
sort of fundamental in a lot
of the architecture and how it
makes it difficult to do that.
Or just analyzing
different ways in which we
are able to allow
people with disabilities
to be more integrated
into society,
and how society has
to potentially change
their viewpoint a little
bit to allow that to happen
to a greater degree.
ARTHI VEZHAVENDAN: The most
engaging aspect was definitely
working with all of the
people in the course,
So my three other team
members and our client,
which, like I said, you don't
entirely get in other courses.
And in this one,
you're sitting down
with the person who is going
to be using the product.
And that was the most
engaging, because I
knew it was going
to be fruitful,
and I knew something was going
to come out of it at the end.
DIRK STAHLECKER: I mean, as far
as an education perspective,
at least, on this, I found
this is a course where
I was motivated to
do the best I could,
not by getting a good
grade or even as much
about learning something
as it was about I really
wanted to help the client.
And I think it's the
client-centered focus
of the course that
really drives it.
And that is I feel the
most important aspect,
because when you're working
with someone one on one,
they're relying on you to
create something that you
know is going to help them.
You are really well
motivated to do the best
you can on that product.
And I think that making sure
that that emphasis is retained
is the most important thing to
keep everyone really engaged
in it and to get the
best quality of products
that it's possible
from a class like this.
And that's really the best
way to make it happen,
in my perspective.
ARTHI VEZHAVENDAN:
You're creating
a product for your
client, but you're also
learning more about a
certain person's lifestyle.
And so make sure
to go beyond what
you're making as a
product, but get to know
your client as a person.
And that's definitely going
to be even more fruitful,
because then you're
not just focused
on this one product,
product, product,
but you're learning more of
how does this one person have
to live with their
disabilities, and how can you
integrate so many other
things in your environment
to help them and these types of
people outside of the semester.